having failed to defeat President Trump
in his successful quest to erase Barack
Obama's legacy and leftist policies
Democrats now stoop to pornography to
smack president co f f/a
we will analyze the role of forbes
paddling porn stars in presidential
politics then an explosive new memo
showing allegedly allegedly detailing
then President Barack Obama's egregious
surveillance of political opponents has
Republican lawmakers demanding it be
released to the public and way way way
when we hold on a second are you trying
to tell me are you trying to say that a
lifelong Chicago politician is corrupt
color me shocked filmmaker Joel Gilbert
joins to discuss his new movie Trump the
art of the insult and finally the
tremendous challenges and successes of
the March for Life
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
there is a lot to get to today we got to
dive right into it but before we do we
have to thank people that I you know I
actually used this just today if you
want to see that smooth little shave on
my face that is Dollar Shave Club a
Dollar Shave Club is great you've heard
me talk about them before I get an
amazing shave from my Dollar Shave Club
razor especially when I use their dr.
Carver's shave butter which is really
nice it's not quite like a gel it's not
quite like that frothy stuff it's just
really really nice on your skin I am
here to tell you that I'm not giving up
that membership I am adding even more
Dollar Shave Club products to my daily
routine so they have a lot of stuff
you've heard about these guys before
it's so simple guys I know what happens
you buy a razor maybe buy a nicer razor
or you use those little throw aways and
then about seven years goes by and you
haven't changed your blade or gone to
the pharmacy or whatever just sign up
for Dollar Shave Club it is super cheap
it will send this to you right to your
door it's it's really inexpensive and
the quality of the products is really
good so and now they do more than just
shave they make products for your hair
face skin shower everything you need
they use only the finest premium
ingredients and they deliver it to you
this appeals to my millennial miss
because I never ever want to over pay or
leave my chair I know I used to it so
this means no more annoying trips to the
store are you going up and down the
aisle you don't know where the razors
are you go up and down you end up buying
a lot of candy and whatever you know
whatever you do at the pharmacy so I use
it for everything razors body cleanser
hair gel and eat this is you know this
is a family show so I don't want to get
too too into the water closet about this
but if you find that you want to be a
little European but you don't have
access to a bidet there are certain
tools that will be sent to you by Dollar
Shave Club to cleanse your derriere make
sure to do it that leg be civilized be
European Western civilization is
ascending again so a Dollar Shave Club
has you covered head to toe and
everything in between now is a great
time to join Dollar Shave Club you
should try it you will get your first
month of their best razor along with
travel size size versions of shave
butter body cleanser and yes even the
derriere
reformulate er for just $5 that is a
really really good deal this is a real
just the razor alone is a really high
quality plus you get all the other stuff
it is virtually free you get it for just
5 bucks
after that replacement cartridges will
ship for just a few bucks a month
it is the DSC starter set dollar shave
club get yours for just five dollars
basically for free exclusively at
dollarshaveclub.com
slash coffe FA CoV Fe Fe that's
dollarshaveclub.com slash co FFA what is
it Marshall cafe CoV Fe Fe do it and get
you covered head to toe and you'll feel
really good and pampered and ready to go
face the day go on do it's the 21st
century stop going to drugstores go do
this those will be economical and you'll
feel a lot better Dollar Shave Club comm
slash Co ff8 okay
let's get right into this I want to talk
a little bit first about stormy Daniels
you can't go on everything I had is gone
stormy Daniels let's address it
Democrats are peddling some totally
unreliable tabloid trash that 12 years
ago a porn star spanked the president
with a copy of Forbes magazine let me
just state this for the record I would
much rather have the president who is
titillated by Forbes magazine over the
one who's aroused by Saul Alinsky any
day of the week rules from for radicals
give me the former what is the story
here the mainstream media have been
peddling this rumor that Trump had an
affair with a porn star in 2006 the porn
star in question stormy Daniels denies
vehemently that anything took place she
stated On January 10th quote I recently
became aware that certain news outlets
are alleging that I had a sexual and/or
romantic affair with Donald Trump many
many many years ago I am stating with
complete clarity that this is absolutely
false my involvement with Donald Trump
was limited to a few public appearances
and nothing more when I met Donald Trump
he was gracious professional and a
complete gentleman to me and everyone in
my presence rumors that I've received
hush money from Donald Trump are
completely false if indeed I did have a
relationship with Donald Trump trust me
you wouldn't be reading about it in the
news you would be reading about it in my
but the fact of the matter is these
stories are not true does kind of sound
like a trump might have written that but
it does gonna Trump Ian's vibe but I
don't know it could be as friends might
write that way too now in touch weekly
is claiming to have a 2011 interview in
which Daniels described the affair in
lurid detail what does this mean for one
thing it means that none of this story
is credible why is that because if the
2011 interview is legitimate the
interviewee is a confirmed liar if the
affair happened she lied in the letter
if the affair didn't happen she lied in
the interview either way if the
interview is legitimate her word is
worthless Antonin Scalia explained this
principle about leaked information at
the Supreme Court a court clerks are
prohibited from speaking to the press
they promise not to speak to the press
so if when they do leaked to the press
if someone does their word isn't
valuable and so their information is not
reliable doesn't mean it isn't true
necessarily just means it isn't reliable
the source that you getting the
information from is very much in
question so onto the accusation itself
there's nothing new here we know that
Donald Trump has had extramarital
affairs in past decades he's admitted to
it he's even bragged about it
president Trump's personal moral
failings were built into the price of
voting for him in 2016 and at the end of
that calculation the American people
preferred the loudmouth Lech with a
patriotic plan - the feckless leftist
crook particularly after Barack Obama
spent eight years spanking our
collective derriere with rules for
radicals that left America less secure
less rich and less free
let's also forget the Clinton
comparisons the Bill Clinton rather
Trump has not perjured himself about
this he hasn't gotten creative with
interns and cigars in the Oval Office we
knew what we were getting when we hired
that man and that's the operative word I
think frequently people make an idol out
of the presidency particularly people
who are atheistic or anti-clerical and
in this culture which is both
everybody's got to serve somebody and so
we imbue the president the presidency
with papal Magisterium let's keep some
perspective let's keep some important
perspective here we hire the President
to do a job so he has to perform certain
tasks he needs to command the military
make treaties appoint ambassadors judges
and other public officials give to the
Congress information
the state of the union recommend
legislation and faithfully execute the
laws by all measures president Trump for
as so far rather performed those duties
Abele better than many if not most of
his predecessors and that's why they
were digging up this trash but that's
why it's coming up now Democrats they
can't hit Trump on substantive matters
because he's been great on substantive
matters and he's been highly
conservative and he's been highly
effective so they have to abase
themselves even further with this
pornography they dig up and report a
long discarded tabloid interview we're
canted by the very pornstar who gave it
with the economy soaring with the world
order in recovery tax reform
deregulation originalist judicial
appointments desperate democrats and
frivolous republicans have to make
themselves pimps to smack the man who
made them look like fools ignore the
porn and let the good times roll now
before we get to joel because i really
want to talk about this movie it's very
entertaining i also want to mention the
story about an apparently explosive
document that could undermine the muller
investigation here is Republican
congressman gates describing him well
Liz the allegations contained in this
important intelligence document go to
the very foundations of our democracy
and they require an immediate release to
the public in my opinion unfortunately I
cannot talk about the specific facts
contained within this memo I can only
share my observation that if the
American people knew what was happening
if they saw the contents of this memo a
lot would become clear about the
information that I've been talking about
on television for the last several
months and so I am calling on our
leadership to immediately hold a vote on
the floor of the house to make public
the key contents of this intelligence
memo regarding the FBI the Department of
Justice and President Trump the critical
allegations I cannot stress how
important they are in this memo the
Judiciary Committee would likely find
the contents of this memo very
interesting very revealing and and just
essential to the way our government
interacts with the duly elected
president of the United States this is
no small measure it is just as important
as keeping the government open through
the weekend and we need to have a vote
on it immediately Congressman Steve King
has said I have read the memo the sick
reality has set in I no longer hold out
hope that there is an innocent
explanation for the information the
public has seen I have long said it is
worse than Watergate it was hashtag
never Trump and hashtag always Hillary
hashtag released the memo Ron de santis
has said quote the classified report
compiled by House Intelligence is deeply
troubling and raises serious questions
about the upper echelon of the Obama DOJ
and Comey FBI as it relates to the so
called collusion investigation
congressman Scott Perry compared a
parent government collusion with
Democrats to the KGB Gates says there
are criminal implications people will go
to jail even Lindsey Graham has referred
the fusion GPS author Christopher Steele
for criminal investigation that's a
Lindsey Graham a rather moderate
Republican no personal fan of Donald
Trump what does this all mean one theory
is that the entire FBI investigation
began because of the Democrat fund
infusion GPS dossier meaning that the
federal government became political
enforcers for Democrats to throw an
election I spoke to a high-level source
this morning and he informed me that
Barack Obama's ambassador to the UN
Samantha power may be implicated in all
of this in October Samantha power denied
that in the final months of the Obama
administration she initiated well over
100 unmasking x' to identify americans
whose names turned up in foreign
intelligence reporting specifically
members of the trump campaign at the
time a spokesman for power said quote
the anonymously sourced reports about
ambassador powers intelligence requests
are false now the source I spoke to this
morning suggests that that was a lie the
Russia collusion story always seemed
like a distraction Democrat ranking
member of the Judiciary Committee Dianne
Feinstein admitted they have no evidence
of nefarious dealings and Van Jones
called the story a nothing burger now we
have to wonder if perhaps the Russia
collusion story wasn't merely a
distraction
for more nefarious dealings on the part
of Democrats and the corrupt Chicago
machine politician sitting in the Oval
Office when it all went down okay on a
lighter note all of us collusion and the
government conspiring against
Republicans well I need a lighter note
let's bring on Joel Gilbert Joel is the
filmmaker behind one of the most Kofi
Fae movies ever
assembled Donald Trump in the art of the
insult I think I even have a copy right
here I'm gonna prop it up with my flex
toxic effect a soup can it is
he's also released two films oh my gosh
this is a disaster I blame the FBI and
James Comey
so joel has also released the film's
Paul McCartney really is dead the last
Testament of George Harrison Elvis found
alive and dreams for my real father
a story of Reds and deception here is a
clip from his latest film
[Music]
they said that wasn't politically
correct who cares
you have been called go back to
Univision I think Jeb is a nice person
it's very low-energy I'm not used to
that kind of a person
[Music]
throw them out throw them out into the
dog
give them their coat no coats
[Music]
[Applause]
I have never seen a human being eat in
such a disgusting fashion the most
dishonest human be sees people right
here look at all the cat
[Applause]
this socialist-slash-communist crazy
birdies tres
[Music]
crazier than a bedbug pogon its Joel
thank you for being here thanks to have
appreciate you doing it I really enjoyed
watching the movie so let's get right
into it
my first question what is the secret of
the art of the insult Donald Trump's
secret of course I guess it starts with
some New York hutzpah that he's willing
to stand his ground and with that he
comes up with branding of his opponents
people forget that Donald Trump was in
the entertainment business for thirty
years they think of him as a real estate
guy right but he was doing a
professional wrestling pro boxing Miss
America Miss Universe of course The
Apprentice he owned a USFL football team
so he has seen and done it all when it
came to marketing and hype and being in
New York he knew how to manipulate the
media very easily so he came up with his
brand names for his opponents and they
were so effective because they had a
little mix of truth and humor the first
one that most people remember that was
so effective was of course low energy
Jeb it killed him it totally destroyed
jeb Bush's presidential yeah I mean 120
million dollars in the bank and Trump
came along with a marketing concept
called Low Energy and he had very little
money he had this massive office in
Trump Tower with three guys in it and he
would fly around in the you know Trump
airplane and landed these hangars on
this Trump Appaloosa tour and you know
20,000 people waiting five six seven
times a day and he'd go into this
hilarious performance art where he'd
mimic and imitate the people that he was
branding and it was so entertaining and
so much fun
he was able to use this performance art
in combination with the branding to just
destroy his opponents and the the media
just fell right into it one of the
funniest things I would always you could
just tell that the protesters would come
to protest they say we're gonna stop
Donald Trump we're gonna embarrass him
and you know we're gonna make him look
bad and as soon as they would start
protesting he would suddenly smile he'd
say look looked at the protesters and
they didn't realize that they were the
ones that were drawing all the media
right to Trump's event so he got two
billion
as in freer and media just by
manipulating everybody who is masterful
well his entire campaign it seemed to me
was some insults some fairly clear
policy proposals and cheap hats and that
was it he got two billion dollars of
free media out of it what was it about
his insults that was so sticky because
they didn't all stick he tried out a few
on Hillary he tried out low stamina
Hillary that didn't really stick but
crooked Hillary was perfect low energy
Jeb was perfect what was it about that
wording that made it so highly effective
well some of them were not as effective
like calling out Carly Fiorina for her
face that was kind of off limits for a
woman to talk about her look so
Pocahontas worked on Elizabeth Warren
because it was something that had been
around for a few years
lyin Ted Cruz it really required a lot
of explanation it was particularly
hurtful and it was very skillful because
Cruz's number-one asset was he was
considered to be very honest yeah
constitutional Republican and somebody
who stood for principle so he was really
going after his strength that was the
the brilliance of that one and it kind
of unnerved Cruz he kind of fell apart
and I felt that one was very aesthetic
because I like Ted Cruz a lot I don't
think he's a liar I thought it was a
fairly serious and straightforward
candidate but he looks like a liar he
just has a look about him he even has
talked about this and so it almost
seemed to me that Donald Trump was
playing on what you saw in front of your
face rather even than what Cruz was
doing in the campaigns or in his Senate
career let me take comments about Cruz
look Ted I spent a lot of time with
Republican base voters over the past
five six years with my film I'm known
for dreams so my real father there's no
place like utopia and it was clear that
the Republican base had moved far to the
right of the establishment and Cruz
played a big part in that he went around
of course he was widely admired first
guy to stand up to Obama on the
Obamacare red green eggs and ham on the
Senate floor he was the
anti-establishment hero and actually
advised Cruz I worked with the campaign
and I told Ted and the campaign I said
look Ted just needs to beat Ted Cruz the
rebel the outsider mr. Cruz goes to
Washington I told him it was his to lose
but they went for more of
establishment campaign a chairman in
every state every County no strong
marketing message he tried to move to
the middle he kind of wanted to be Jeb
Bush so Donald Trump came along and said
okay if you don't want to be Ted Cruz
you can argue the drain the swamp
candidate was Ted Cruz originally but he
he dropped it off and Trump came and Ted
won the election but it was in the
person of Donald Trump and on that Trump
was so unconcealed Tory there was no
moment they I loved that moment when he
said something about anchor babies and
the journalist interviewing him said
don't you know that's offensive he said
well I know it's not politically correct
but what would you prefer and the guy
says you know I don't know future
American and undocumented whatever Trump
looks at amigos yeah I'm gonna stick
with anchor baby what is it about that
cutting through the politically correct
pristine images we see from politicians
totally constructed in a laboratory
Trump cut through that like butter is it
something about our moment that we're in
right now that made that work or could a
candidate have done it ten years ago
would work just as well I think it would
have worked as well the American public
had been had abused by Barack Obama for
eight years don't forget he ran as a
mainstream candidate I'm gonna cut the
deficit in half I'm gonna obey the
Constitution marriage is between a man
and a woman in God he made it clear that
he's mainstream he never intended to do
any of that it was an intentional lie
and think about evil a plan that is to
come up with a fake agenda to try to get
elected and that Obama is really the
story of how American socialism changed
from the late 60s it was cause for open
revolution let's destroy the
Constitution let's put 50 million
Americans in encamps and murder half of
them that's what The Weather Underground
and Bill Ayers were were pushing they
went to jail because it was so evil they
went about Barack Obama's buddy Billy
correct right so what had the way
American socialism evolved was these
guys came out of jail and out of prison
in the early eighties went back to
Chicago into these educational
institutions and the old radicals talked
the new group of young radicals like
Barack Obama they said look you cannot
overthrow the government from the
outside it won't work so keep your
socialism dear
keep your Marxism inside and just tell
people you want to help families you
want to give them free health care and
once you take power you'll throw them
under the bus and pursue the radical
agenda that nobody voted for well we saw
this in Obama Obama said my health care
plan is going to lower costs for
everybody they're not gonna get snot
attacks and no one's costs are gonna go
up and then when obviously costs
Roza precipitously he said well you
didn't think you were gonna get all that
good stuff for free did you so yes we
did you told us that we've got so there
was a collective rage in the public that
we've been had we've been abused we've
been lied to Barack Obama interfere in
the 2012 election with the IRS the the
Conservatives were suppressed from
organizing while the left could organize
and then you know we didn't need any
Russian interference in 2012 we had our
own Bolshevik in the White House using
the tools of state to maintain power and
now we're seeing he did it again with
the DOJ and FBI so he promised us and in
2012 right he said to Medvedev he said
I'm gonna have more flexibility after my
election as if to say I am going to lie
to the American public about my plans
but then I'll be nicer to you when I'm
in office and the classic response was
duh I feel transmit this information to
Vladmir yeah it's like an old spy movie
I might almost call war you know I'm
unbelievable you almost think that maybe
the Russians had something on Obama but
Donald Trump picked up on that wave and
he was part of that and that's why
middle America fell in love with this
Manhattan billionaire and I think in the
movie in Trump the other of the insult
it takes you through this rollicking
ride you just can't stop laughing and
kind of cheering and I thought I
understood Trump I read books about him
I talked to people who knew him for 30
years I thought I knew Trump only when I
put the movie together when you see all
of this back-to-back you see him
reacting from and how authentic he is
and that's why he said what he said he
meant what he said and even if it was a
little odd or off-the-wall sometimes you
still wanted to vote for him whereas
when Hillary spoke you really couldn't
figure out what she was saying and if
you did you didn't believe her and you
yeah you had to parse what she really
meant she said this and well I know that
ink in Clinton Clinton is right this
really means that and this really means
that and you have to try to parse it
with prompt you didn't reel
have to and that's one thing I really
like about the movie is that it provides
this great collection of just all of
these hilarious Trump moments a very
effective Trump moments critics of
President coffe FA say that he is
debasing the moral and political
discourse of the United States because
he has these zingers and he's a brash
billionaire from Queens do you think
there's a moral hazard to this loose
talk from the president the straight
talk from the president or let the good
times roll we're getting great
government out of it stop your pearl
collection you know you got a look he
all Trump is doing is standing up for
himself he's standing his ground he's
standing his turf if people violate the
rules like Dianne Feinstein you know
she's sneaky Dianne Feinstein so he's
branding her he's continuing to to do
what he does best which is to call out
his opponents and defend himself the
don't forget that what did Barack Obama
do he abused the electorate every single
day called Americans racist on every
occasion that he could he used the the
government to do all kinds of nefarious
things calling uh telling people there's
an evil boogeyman that has your money
the top 1% is taking all your money give
me the power raise tax so what Trump has
done in comparison to Obama's
transgressions is nothing he's standing
his ground and I think if he continues
to do that and you know stays the
authentic Queens street fighter that
people voted for they wanted a fight or
it didn't matter when he told Jorge
Ramos you know go back to Univision it
right there you could say the election
was over it was early on because people
wanted a fighter and it wasn't about
yeah Jorge Ramos it was about this guy
will stand up to Hillary he will we see
the strength here and we want to see the
next episode of the show and so my last
question can he win in 2020 and how will
he do it
look he's up against a Democrat Party
that is an anti democracy party there
now a radical socialist party as soon as
Trump was elected two million
anti-democracy protesters took to the
streets the Democrat leaders call for
resistance now resistance is a military
term the anti-nazi partisans use
resistance right
terrorists are there in resistance now
you know democracy it's called
opposition not resistance like an
opposing opinion and they're always
shocked to find out that anyone holds a
different opinion than they do they're
very tolerant until someone has a
different opinion exactly but they use
this revile its violent rhetoric and
that's why we saw that guy James
Hutchinson the leftist activists tried
to murder the top Republican leaders and
gravely injured Steve Scalise so Trump
has the entire media complex against him
the the Democrat Party willing to shut
down the government will need to do
anything to stop him because if he's
successful it it reveals how bankrupt
their policies are their economics and
their leftist agenda to divide the
country and pit people against each
other so he's up against a very
formidable array of very entrenched
enemies I think he can prevail because
the American people understand him and
they're on his side and if he continues
to just be himself and stand his ground
I think the Republicans will be very
successful in 2008 despite the constant
negative press cough fa where can people
get the movie Trump the order the insult
well if they're in the LA area they can
see the will premiere screening in
Encino on Tuesday night next week the
23rd it is available amazon.com Best Buy
Barnes & Noble everywhere you find
digital downloads or DVDs this coming
Tuesday the 23rd you can buy the DVD or
stream it online check it out you're
going to enjoy a drill thank you for
being here thanks so much all right I
we've got to close off I've got a little
bit to say about the March for Life you
know that thing that the mainstream
media refused to cover the largest
longest continual protest in the history
of America but before we do that I have
to say goodbye to you I'm sorry if
you're on the daily wire comm we
appreciate it you help us keep the cafe
in our cup and the lights on if you are
on Facebook and YouTube I got to say
goodbye guys I go to daily wire right
now what do you get you get me you get
the intro Clavin show you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get to ask questions in
the conversation next episode is going
to be little old me you get no ads on
the website forget all of that
once Trump the art of the insult debuts
next Tuesday in Encino there's going to
be a flood if we had a lot of fires and
LA has been dry for decades it is going
to flood and you're going to need this
this is
the leftist here's tumblr it is going
away you do not know the day or the hour
but make sure you get your copy of it
before it is gone otherwise you and your
family could drown we will be right back
go over to Daly wired.com
[Music]
[Music]
the March for Life tens of thousands of
people right now are marching on
Washington DC for the 45th annual March
for Life never heard of it you're not
alone even many conservatives don't
really know anything about it because
the mainstream media generally black the
event out which is really incredible by
the way as the March for Life is the
longest continual protest in American
history they've been marching ever since
the Supreme Court's decision in roe v
wade that made up a constitutional right
to abortion you know you know that thing
with the framers were so concerned about
abortion giveme abortion or give me
death
I forget exactly which article that
right to abortion is in but if you read
the Constitution very very closely and
then you invent that right out of whole
cloth you should find it pro-life
supporters have come in from all over
the country and their efforts have not
been in vain five years ago in 2013 the
number of annual abortions fell below 1
million for the first time in 40 years
and that number has slowly continued to
drop of course that means there are
still roughly 1 million babies killed in
the womb each year with maniacal ghouls
like Cecile Richards of Planned
Parenthood snuffing out a third of them
Planned Parenthood alone has killed more
than 7 million babies in the womb
since roe v-- wade and as the Center for
medical progress expose showed us
Planned Parenthood has profited
marvelously by selling babies body parts
on the black market to the highest
bidder
since roe v-- wade well over 60 million
abortions have occurred in the united
states to put that in perspective that's
the total population of South Carolina
Louisiana Kentucky Oregon Oklahoma
Connecticut Iowa Mississippi Arkansas
Utah Kansas Nevada New Mexico Nebraska
West Virginia Idaho Hawaii Maine New
Hampshire Rhode Island Montana Delaware
South Dakota Alaska North Dakota
Washington DC Vermont and Wyoming
combined today as many people identify
as pro-life as pro-choice up
tremendously over the past four decades
despite the constant slew of
pro-abortion propaganda from the
mainstream media and Hollywood cynical
politicians scare monger they say that
without abortion before roe v-- wade
without roe v-- wade thousands of women
would die
year from back-alley abortions from
coathanger abortions the former head of
the National Abortion Rights Action
League Bernard Nathanson has since
admitted that he and his pro-abortion
conspirators completely invented that
number it was totally made up it's a
total lie in reality by 1972 the year
before a roe v-- wade when abortion was
still illegal in the majority of the
country the actual number of women who
died from illegal abortions was
thirty-nine not thirty-nine thousand not
3939 the wilder statistic is that that
same year 24 women died from legal
abortions despite legal abortion only
existing in a small percentage of states
the mass slaughter has taken a
disproportionate toll on racial
minorities in New York City more black
babies are aborted than born this is no
coincidence Margaret Sanger the founder
of Planned Parenthood was a committed
eugenicist to explained quote to
understand the difficulties and the
obstacles to be overcome before the
dream of a greater race in America can
be attained is to understand something
of the task before the women who shall
give birth to that race among our more
than 100 million population are Negroes
Indians Chinese and other colored people
- the number of 11 million
there are also 14 million 500,000
persons of foreign birth there were 1
million six hundred thousand illiterate
foreigners in the United States when the
1910 census was taken do these elements
give promise of a better race are we
doing anything genuinely constructive to
overcome this situation that's from her
book woman and the new race and they did
get very constructive reaching the
climax during roe v-- wade future
generations will look on our tolerance
of abortion with the same horror and
moral opprobrium with which we view
slaveholders in the antebellum south
which side will that history record you
as having taken good luck to everybody
in the march on life doing great work
and it's and it's really great that our
president President Trump has for the
first time as a sitting president a
sitting president has addressed that
march of life in DC really good stuff
thank you very much for being here I'm
pleasant nice to do a Friday showed it I
usually don't do that we'll be back on
Monday the last episode of another
Kingdom and drew Flavin's podcast that I
perform the last the final installment
the great climax is there please go over
download it wherever SuperDuper COFA a
narrative podcasts are downloaded please
leave us a review it really helps us out
send it to your friends share it tweet
it insta carrier pigeon whatever you got
to do thank you very much I'm Michael
Moses is the Michael no sure I'll see
you Monday
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer mathis Glover
our technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex Zingara audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mina hair and makeup is by
Jeshua ov era the Michael Noel's show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for word publishing
2018